all right let's jump into the paternity
leave debate now i i
to even get into this i think it's
important to mention
that the recent hubbub about secretary
of transportation pete budeh judges
paternity leave it's not even
necessarily about paternity leave
there's a homophobic aspect of this
which is the feminization of a gay man
like pete edge edge taking paternity
leave which really should be for moms
it's really for women has he been
learning how to breastfeed tucker
carlson said feminizing a gay man so
there's like there's a homophobic aspect
to it that's that's one piece of it
there's another piece of it which for
some people it's just political
opportunism which is
under trump
the republicans weren't blaming trump
for the supply shortages that we had
early during the pandemic
under trump republicans weren't blaming
trump's secretary of transportation
elaine chao
now those very same republicans are
blaming joe biden
and blaming pete buddha judge so for
some it's political opportunism but then
there's also an aspect of this which
kind of feels more psychological either
like a my dad wasn't around when i was
little so there should nobody should get
paternity leave kind of like a if i
can't play in the sandbox i'm going to
poop in it and shut the whole thing down
um or
also kind of a um
antiquated tropes of uh it being
feminine to
take time off when you've had a kid
right so there's a lot of different
motivations for different people
the latest is joe rogan
weighing in on this during an interview
he did with a bridgette bridgette fedeci
fatassi i'm not exactly sure how her
last name is pronounced i believe she's
a comedian
um and again they get into this issue of
pete bootage edges paternity leave uh
let's take a listen and then we'll we'll
discuss what's crazy is that pete budded
judge during this whole time is on
paternity leave
and you just so what they mean is during
the supply shortages that we're having
this entire time pete buddha judges on
paternity leave i wanna go listen man i
understand it's hard to raise a child
but um
isn't that supposed to be for the person
who gave birth
it's crazy yeah right now over 70 ships
containing 500 000 containers are
waiting off shore 500 but he was saying
now
those ships pete bootage doesn't control
those ships p bootage edge is one guy a
country of 330 million people even if
you believe that it's the department of
transportation that controls those ships
there's a deputy secretary of
transportation and an undersecretary of
transportation the idea that it's
because pete is holding a baby
instead of a phone even though he's
actually been participating in in
meetings anyway the ships are stuck it's
it's such a silly childish idea it's
like this negative feedback loop that is
rapidly cycling out of control that if
it continues on a beta will destroy the
global economy i'm like that's a nice
one to just slide in there okay
yeah
um so it's complicated but i do know the
trucking stuff has something to do with
it too because there was already
problems with truckers they kind of
abandoned california that's what it
looked like two years ago this is a
visualization of like the data they used
so we're watching trucks this is a
couple of couple ships just a couple
ships this is 2019. since last week
why are there so many
because they're all i mean this is why
that's why yeah because they're stuck
yeah they're all floating around out
here waiting to find space to come into
there to go wait and they can kind of
get in there like you said if there's
only seven out of hundreds of cranes
emptying them then they're waiting
it's nuts
it's nuts and that's why you can't buy
toys and it's also affecting small
businesses yeah you know okay so the
point here is they're blaming pete
buddha judge for this and isn't it women
that are supposed to take leave when
there's a kid born not the men now
interestingly spotify
for which you know joe rogan now
licenses his show works for spotify you
use whatever term you want
they give six months of leave regardless
of gender
which is which is interesting uh the
other thing about this actually let's
look at let's look at one more clip
because i have some other thoughts but
they're relevant to this next part i'm
and i'm questioning what who do you
believe
should pay for something like i don't
know but if i was an employer
and i had a guy who worked for me i had
a guy work for me he wanted to take
three months off because his wife gave
birth i'd be like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about mike
even to support his wife give birth to
support his wife while i pay him for
free
do you understand that this is kind of
most people when this happens
if they make enough money the wife will
not work and the father will work right
now
that might be plausible
if the man makes more money
uh i have friends where um
the wife
is a doctor and makes more money i have
friends where the wife is a lawyer and
makes more money and it really doesn't
make sense what joe rogan is actually
saying
um and so even that already is based on
a whole this is just basically
it's a suicide
when you assume
you got you guys know the thing okay all
right
and then the wife takes care of the
child
and this is normal yeah and then normal
what does that mean these are such
loaded terms and unfortunately this was
not you know i think if someone else was
speaking to joe rogan about this you
could say what do you mean normal do you
mean it's historically typical
based on
something that started during an era
where often women didn't work at all and
were less educated than men which has
been completely reversed at this point
you know it's it's this very kind of
like
1950s
thinking that's not really relevant
today the dad provides support when he
comes home if you're saying that the man
and the woman
should both get like three months off
this is a new thing yeah right new isn't
bad now like that's also fallacious
continuing to do something the way it
used to be done
is not an argument the fact that it used
to be a different way is not actually an
argument it's not new in europe but
we're not in europe
this is better
okay and so then then we add in this
idea of
in europe the men are feminized they're
[ __ ] men here in the united states
we're manly so it's like they're hitting
all the different tropes here now i want
to introduce a different kind of
question into this
you know there's this movement um
they're called men's rights activists
now there are people who believe some of
the things men rights activists believe
and they're not actually men's rights
activists i think it's important to say
they just kind of
gravitate towards the ideology in some
areas but there's this whole movement
which is about complaining
women get preferential treatment on
everything in the united states men get
the shaft when it comes to
uh divorce
men get the shaft and women get
preferential treatment when it comes to
police interactions around domestic
violence
women get preferential treatment and men
get the shout you know all this
different stuff
you would think that they would be
saying hey you know what this is great
women have gotten the preferential
treatment on maternity leave at all or
paid maternity leave now
we're equalizing it the men aren't going
to get the shaft anymore
but that's not the perspective of many
of those very same people so just it's
all stereotypical tropes the europeans
as the [ __ ] girly men
real men don't need time off in the u.s
i'm gonna go to work and then i'll come
home and then i'll hold the baby or
whatever it's just very antiquated stuff
and then the other thing again the
context of blaming p buddha judge
country of 330 million people the idea
that everything depends on one guy who's
home with his kids these issues started
under trump no one blamed transportation
secretary under trump elaine chao it's
pathetic last possible angle
is it possible that there are people
that are worked up about this
whose dads weren't around when they were
kids their dads didn't have any
paternity leave never mind paid
paternity leave
and they're transferring that into the
same type of thing we're seeing with
student loans listen i had to pay my
student loans so we shouldn't forgive
them for anybody listen
my dad wasn't around when i was a kid so
there shouldn't be paternity leave now
is there maybe that psychological
element that's affecting some people's
view on this as well i'm not talking
about joe rogan i have no idea his
family history
these are general uh questions that that
i have i'd be curious to hear your
thoughts
if you follow me on social media you
know i love growing my own food in my
backyard garden and our sponsor lettuce
grow has made growing food at home
simpler than ever the lettuce grow farm
stand is a vertical stand that can be
inside or outside where you can grow
over 200 varieties of fruits and
vegetables the farm stand waters and
fertilizes itself it does all the work
for you you can grow up to 36 plants at
a time
lettuce grow sends you the seedlings and
then your food is ready to eat in four
to six weeks i've had a great experience
with the lettuce grow farm stand i've
been growing delicious tomatoes
strawberries eggplant it only takes up
four square feet fits anywhere i can
move it around very very easy
growing your own food is so rewarding
lettuce grow makes it easy for anyone
and lettuce grow is giving my audience
50 off the farm stand just go to
lettucegrow.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below